Leonie Hanne bei der Arbeit.
Die 33-jährige deutsche Influencerin ist
bei der Fashion-Show von Dior in Paris.
Dort sitzt sie in der ersten Reihe –
selbstverständlich
im neuesten Look der Marke.
Das französische Luxus-Label ist
ein sogenannter Partner,
mit dem die Influencerin
seit einigen Jahren zusammenarbeitet.
Ich wollte eigentlich
’nen silbernen Look anziehen.
Und dann hat einer der
allergrößten VIPs ’nen ähnlichen Look.
Und da hat mich heute Morgen
Dior angerufen und mir gesagt:
„Bitte ändere den Look.“
Und zum Glück hatte ich noch
was in der Reserve.
Deswegen wurde es jetzt
ungeplant bunt.
Während der Schauen,
wie hier bei der Pariser Modewoche,
jagt ein Termin den nächsten.
Festgehalten wird alles
auf ihrem Instagram-Account.
Mit fast vier Millionen Followern
gehört Leonie Hanne
zu den erfolgreichsten
Mode-Influencern Europas.
Gott sei Dank interessieren sich meine
Follower tatsächlich für das, was wir tun.
Ich bin zum Beispiel jetzt in Paris
besser gewachsen als im letzten Jahr,
obwohl wir so viel gepostet haben.
Man könnte auch denken,
den Leuten ist [es] zu viel.
Aber es bringt richtig Spaß, weil ich sehe,
wie die Community mitgeht.
Und dann fühlt man sich auch
an ’nem anstrengenden Tag
immer so voller Motivation.
Man weiß, da sitzen Leute,
und die gucken zu und sagen so:
„Nächstes Outfit, nächster Look!“
Das bringt Spaß. Ist richtig, richtig schön.
Influencer wie sie sind die Stars von heute.
Leonie Hanne hat ihren eigenen Chauffeur.
Wenn sie unterwegs ist,
wohnt sie im 5-Sterne-Hotel
und wird von den Marken hofiert.
Doch was nach einem Luxusleben aussieht,
ist auch harte Arbeit.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
das Gegenteil von glamourös.
Umso glamouröser es aussieht,
umso weniger glamourös war es meistens.
Also, wir haben uns jetzt gesagt,
wir waren in Venedig
und in Cannes bei den Filmfestspielen,
und umso schicker es aussieht…
Die Leute denken so:
„Wow, living the best life!“
Das ist in echt fünf Stunden Arbeit,
drei Minuten Red Carpet,
viel laufen, viel rennen.
Und die Leute denken,
der ganze Tag war nur in Roben.
Aber in echt ist es immer anders,
als man denkt.
Aber es gehört auch dazu,
das dann irgendwie so zu verpacken,
dass es nur nach Glam aussieht.
Wenn Leonie Hanne
auf den Modenschauen unterwegs ist,
muss sie sich meistens im Auto umziehen.
Mehrmals am Tag wechselt sie das Outfit.
Wir fragen einmal kurz den Fahrer,
ob er rausgeht,
dann haben mein Freund und ich Platz.
Ich zieh’ mich um –
und bevor ich das Auto verlasse,
guckt er eigentlich.
Wenn also was nicht passt,
ist es seine Schuld.
Ohne Fahrer schafft man tatsächlich
nicht mehrere Shows in ’ner Reihe,
weil man sich gar nicht umziehen kann.
Weil, man könnte nie:
Show-Hotel, Show-Hotel …
man muss eigentlich: Show-Show-Show,
und dafür braucht man die Looks
schon im Kofferraum.
Immer an ihrer Seite:
Lebens- und Geschäftspartner
Alexander Galievsky.
Kennengelernt haben sich die beiden
beim Wirtschaftsstudium in Hamburg.
Sie arbeiten jetzt
seit sechs Jahren zusammen.
Das, was viele jetzt
beim, beim Bloggen unterschätzen,
ist natürlich,
dass [das] ganz viel Geschäftssinn ist.
Also, wir planen ja selber unseren Schedule,
was wir machen wollen, planen Projekte,
überlegen, wie wir uns irgendwie
vom Image positionieren wollen, ähnliches.
Da gehört ganz viel Betriebswirtschaft dazu.
Für Mode hat sich die gebürtige Hamburgerin
eigentlich schon immer interessiert.
Als bei uns die erste Boutique
aufgemacht hat,
hab’ ich in der Boutique
angefangen zu arbeiten.
Ich war auch mal bei Modelagenturen,
aber ich bin sehr, sehr ehrgeizig,
ein Kopfmensch, analytischer Mensch.
Und mir hat das damals nicht gefallen,
dass man mir quasi gesagt hat,
dass meine Meinung nicht so wichtig ist
und dass ich eigentlich nur abliefern soll,
was man mir sagt.
Das ist heute anders,
Leonie Hanne ist so etwas wie
Model und Geschäftsfrau in einem.
Arbeit, Vergnügen und Privatleben
gehen fließend ineinander über –
und ihre Follower sind stets dabei.